My guess,
lot of the skin today,
our Huron on and Henna gracie brothers
and part of Jujitsu's most illustrious
family as sons.
The holly on Gracie known worldwide for
creating the UFC as a way to bring his
family's Jujitsu style to the attention
of America's masses here on and hen air
have continued to perpetuate their
father's legacy while carving out their
own name in the Jujitsu family tree.
This includes taking Bjj into the
technological age by founding the online
gracie university,
the first interactive distance learning
center for Brazilian Jujitsu,
boasting more than 100,000
students in over 196 countries.
The hugely popular unknown online show,
the gracie breakdown.
There's also seen them amass large
numbers of viewers for their mixed
martial arts commentaries.
Welcome to under the skin here on and
hand and walk them through our house
man,
because here we are in your home stadium
in tolerance.
Could you?
I'm very grateful of being here.
I've like.
So the people at home know,
I've been trained training mostly with
here on for just a one week for five
little five hour long sessions.
And the thing that fascinates me most
about Brazilian Jujitsu,
people that are fans of martial arts
will be aware of its efficacy of its
power.
People that know your family and your
online work.
We'll know that there is a sort of a
peculiar component to what you do as a
marketer martial art,
which I've been particularly struck by a
kind of openness and a kind of warmth
and a kind of love.
There was something about it that
surprises me a great deal to start this
conversation.
Could you explain to me a little about
Helio Gracie and the foundation of what
is known as Gracie Jujitsu,
maybe racy or grandfather for those who
don't know.
Um,
first,
thanks for being here.
This is awesome for us.
We were delighted to get the call that
you were here and one of the train
Jujitsu and for our viewing audience out
there and our listening audience,
um,
Russell has only had a little bit of
training here with us in California,
but he is training in the UK and has
been consistent for a little while.
So it's always beautiful when Jujitsu
has another,
you know,
influential figure like yourself,
join the family and be able to
perpetuate the amazingness of what we
were so lucky to grow up with,
especially someone that's so good at
Jujitsu as I am.
But they laughed.
They laugh.
Listen,
do you have all the attributes?
You've got the legs for the triangle
chokes and you've been incredibly
dedicated.
Um,
but in terms of what you said about,
you know,
the warmth and the amazingness of
Jujitsu,
while you were saying that,
I'm like,
wow,
it makes sense that it's kind of a shock
to someone who gets involved in a
fighting art to be received with the
warmth and the gentility and the,
the,
the beauty of what is the Gracie Jiu
Jitsu,
something that you might not have
associated with it before you kind of
ventured into this,
this,
this art as,
as you begin and,
and you're absolutely right then that we
can trace that back to our grandfather.
But really the core of what Jujitsu is,
right.
Um,
Jujitsu is the most gentle martial art
on the planet and self defense system
while also being the most effective.
So we have the ability to not only
defend ourselves against an attacker,
but if we have to defend ourselves
against someone,
they're not going to get hurt.
They're going to be okay.
What do you think it was in particular
about your grandfather that meant that
Jujitsu,
as he evolved through your family,
has maintained this kind of gentleness?
What was it about him as a man?
Our grandfather was very frail,
very light,
very small as whole life.
So he had to be the most technical
person in the room and because he was so
technical,
naturally he can't rely on his physical
attributes.
He can't go out there and beat people
up.
So the gentility I think started there.
If he was six [inaudible] three,
225 pounds,
maybe it wouldn't have been a gentle
experience for you this week,
but the fact that he was as small as he
was it,
we kind of continued,
you know,
what he was so passionate about,
which was being technical
inception of Jujitsu.
The idea that disadvantages can become
advantages be seeded in it.
The idea that something that would be
considered a disadvantage,
being frail,
being small,
these things can be turned to an
advantage.
That for me already seems like an
interesting philosophical point,
but as well as being like,
of course a uh,
you know,
I love all the gentleness and the warm
for Nada,
but this is not the,
the origins of this are in Brazil.
There's a lot of conflict,
a lot of combat,
a lot of honor,
a lot of your grandfather demonstrate in
the effectiveness of these principles
in,
you know,
fights.
And just tell us a bit about that.
You know,
that's Kinda how the West was won.
It was these challenge matches,
right?
So if you do Jujitsu,
and this guy over here does karate and
both think they are the most effective
martial arts on the planet,
you have to fight to see which one is
more effective.
We have to have a debate.
A debate when it comes to martial arts
is basically a fight.
It's a conversation and they're,
they're done in a spirit of education
and the spirit of exploration.
Our grandfather never considered himself
a professional fighter,
like a prize fighter like you see today
with the,
you know,
the UFC and professional boxers.
He didn't do it for the sport of it or
even for the money of it.
Our grandfather was a teacher of Jujitsu
who fought other people in no rules
settings to prove that did you through
he was teaching was effective.
That was his demonstration of his
effectiveness.
Do you see the difference?
Whereas someone else might just fight
for the sake of getting paid or the fame
of it.
Our grandfather fought because he
believed what he was teaching was
effective and how else could he prove
it.
Then by choking someone out who was much
larger,
much heavier and much more athletic than
him,
must have had phenomenal drive.
Nonetheless.
This,
it must've been,
this is a man that had a personal
mission because to take a Jujitsu from
where it was in what the 1920s is that
right?
Yeah.
23rd is,
yeah,
where it is today.
Of course his sons and your generation.
I've also contributed incredibly to this
transition.
We'll get to the UFC and that kind of
stuff and your father's work with that,
but like what do you think,
what do you think drove him?
What made him want to do all that?
He,
you know,
he always tells the stories about what
you do.
Two did for him,
right when he was a very young teenager.
And he started learning these techniques
and how much it helped him,
how he could barely run up a flight of
stairs.
And he was not athletic at all.
He starts learning Jujitsu from watching
and before you know what he's teaching
you in a little bit.
And now he's on the mat teaching a lot.
So jujitsu made took him from this frail
little kid to a superhero to Brazil is
first national sports hero.
So if Jujitsu did so much for him,
he feels like,
you know what?
He felt like I had to show us with the
rest of the world.
How can I not give this if it saved my
life?
So it began his selfish.
It began as I'm doing this right now
because I'm a little skinny little white
kid.
I needed,
I need this for myself for survival.
It began with that,
but it ended with service and now he's
affected just by his actions and those
of his kind of,
uh,
his,
you know,
his future generations.
Um,
his successors,
I should say,
uh,
that the whole world martial arts will
never be the same and can never be
undone for the work that that little guy
did in Brazil.
And then of course the family bringing
into America and our whole lives.
He always said,
you guys Jujitsu,
anybody can do Jujitsu.
It's for anybody.
But like you said,
this is a very gentle place and you were
a little bit surprised as to how
pleasant it was here at Grace
University.
People often think like,
ah,
I don't of Jujitsu is for me.
I don't know.
But any grace he thought,
no,
there's no doubt Jujitsu is for you.
It's for you,
for you,
for you.
And he knew that because it was for him.
And if he could do it,
sure.
Being who he was,
of course you can do,
he is the lowest common denominator.
And if he could do it and grow the way
he did and no one is exempt from the
learning process and the growing process
and also what he believed you had to do
to do Jujitsu was very little.
Somebody might think that Jujitsu is,
you know,
rush.
Somebody overwhelmed them with punches
and take them down and arm bar them.
He to him Jujitsu is simply managing
distance,
good communication,
talking to the person down,
who knows.
It could be a little bit of heat up,
not getting punched in the face,
not getting a headlock,
just simply surviving.
Just things safe for two or three
minutes until somebody breaks the fight
up.
You just did amazing Jujitsu and who
can't use that.
He had a personal mission.
The innocence is comparable to other
way.
A lot of people feel about spirituality,
like people that have experienced
enlightenment.
They think I've got to share this
message with the world or perhaps myself
with recovery from drugs and alcohol.
I have a sort of a comparable sense of,
oh,
I want to help other people with this.
I want people,
I want to,
I feel an obligation that if I can do
this,
other people can do it.
Uh,
it's interesting that that at the point
where uh,
this art was conceived,
it was about someone that,
uh,
you know,
that they were in,
were vulnerable on inefficient or even
as you have said,
like so smaller,
weaker guy.
Uh,
like now this is something that's still
relevant to me learning it because like
as we have discussed when I've been
having the personal sessions,
it's like for me it's about access in an
aspect of myself that I'm not being
comfortable accessing before.
It seems important that within this
forum that you're super efficient.
It could be seen as being about
strength,
domination,
control,
vulnerability.
Is there a significant aspect of it?
Peculiar that that's continued now and
we talk a lot about how the,
the more you learn,
the more you realize how much you don't
know.
Yeah,
I should very,
so the vulnerability,
the moment you step on this mat in this
room,
you're,
you're very vulnerable.
Which is why I guess everybody in the
world is not walking into a Jujitsu
school because they fear,
you know,
maybe being embarrassed or being injured
or being,
you know,
overpowered.
So the,
the vulnerability,
it takes a lot to come in here.
And once you do come in here and start
to really work on that feeling of
vulnerability,
they think the possibilities are
endless.
And with you in particular as you're
learning that the,
what we felt is that we'll show you a
technique and let's see,
a technique only requires 10% of your
strength and energy in that particular
situation.
As someone who's newer to Jujitsu,
you do what most the everyone does,
which is you put 100% of your strength
to accomplish something that only
requires 10% of your strength.
And we laugh about it,
but it's true.
And then when you get in those
positions,
you realize that,
and you even said this to me,
you said,
man,
I'm,
I'm overreacting to the threat stimulus
here because that's all I've ever done
my whole life.
It's when there's a threat or an
uncertain too,
I'm uncomfortable or it's it's fight or
flight,
I fight,
you know,
I go 100% in response to it.
And um,
and I think that you're making a lot of
discovery for yourself as we're doing
this and saying,
wow,
why am I death gripping him right now
when he just told me that I can do it
with 90% less energy and still be
effective?
Why am I doing that?
Right.
And that's important to kind of reflect
on,
well you,
you haven't,
he hasn't taken that technique into
battle.
It's true.
Not tested it enough to trust it like we
do.
I trust the move to where I can use 10%
15% because I know what I believe in
that move.
As much as I believe in anything in the
world,
you just learned it yesterday.
You can't trust that move with your life
trust.
So you have to do it 17 1947300500 times
and then eventually and none of that
with different levels of resistance.
And then eventually you're going to say,
you know what,
somebody is on top of me painting me to
the ground.
This isn't a problem.
Life is great.
No problem.
You know why?
Because I have the trap and roll
because I tell you why,
and this is one of the things I learned
from listening to you guys,
like fear.
It plays a part in me.
It like it.
It's a big part of my psychology.
Even though there's areas in my life
where I feel very competent and
confident,
still fear is very effective.
Now,
while I've been training with you guys
this week,
I've been doing standup comedy gigs and
I told you that even something that I'm
very experienced in doing standup
comedy,
you know,
I feel like,
I feel like it's my job almost to allow
fear to come into me.
I respond to fear that if I'm not
feeling frightened,
I'm not doing it properly,
you know?
But because when I was talking to
actually it was you that said,
hey,
I know that when you are on the green
mat in a fire situation for you,
this is home.
And I was thinking stand up comedy.
That's my home.
I've been doing this a long,
long time,
so the next Gig I did before it,
I fought.
Right now this is my home going into
this place.
It's natural that I feel these feelings
of adrenaline.
It's not true that this energy is coming
into my body but I want to use it.
You said another thing about that guy,
I can't remember his exact name,
but maybe it was called dragon or
something.
Yeah,
Leo Machida,
the Dragon [inaudible] you said that he
says that a fight situation is too
complex to predict the outcome or you
can do is apply your personal fidelity.
Now this for me is a very spiritual
situation,
so before the Gig I was thinking,
I don't know how this Gig,
he's going to go too many variables,
too much chaos.
All I know is if I stay connected to who
I am,
if I can observe it,
then I will be in a good position to lou
use my skills in that area.
I do have trust.
I do have trust days possible to for me
to succeed by like in a new environment.
And one could say this is a very primal
thing you're dealing with,
whether you're male or female.
Fear.
The idea that another human being can
dominate you,
humiliate you,
use you.
This is a energy,
maybe even lizard energy.
This is energy,
this deep,
deep,
deep in the consciousness.
So these techniques I think are posses.
Changing consciousness is changing
consciousness.
It's very important to,
we'll talk more of course about your
family.
We'll talk more about the UFC,
but I'm very interested in the,
uh,
with this phase of the evolution of
Gracie Jujitsu.
You're very interested in programs for
bullying programs for female
empowerment.
Would you like to talk to me a little
bit about that stuff and why it's here?
Well,
that was a big deal for us.
Like we grew up in a family and in an
era where everything was about proving
Jujitsu's effectiveness.
So it was fights.
It was my dad created the UFC to show
that Jujitsu is better than all the
other martial arts and hoist went in
there,
our uncle and did very well and put us
on the map.
Essentially.
Our grandfather did all that previously
in Brazil.
So this proving era was a very
aggressive state of proving,
proving,
proving.
And it came off as,
you know,
as a,
as,
as an era of just showing superiority.
But it was really demonstrating
effectiveness so that students would
say,
wow,
if I'm going to learn something,
I'm going to learn what those,
you know,
skinny Brazilians are doing because I,
if I,
if they could do it,
so can I.
That was the goal there was to inspire
the eagerness to learn that was
accomplished and it basically nine 1993
[inaudible] 94 95 and then since then
it's been a known fact that it's,
your duty was the quintessential art for
mma.
So everyone kind of accepts that.
But where we are today and him and I
coming up through that era and we were,
you know,
early teenagers when that was happening.
And then we had to mature through that
and figure out what was going to be our
calling and what was going to be our
really our focus for the family.
What's our contribution to this legacy?
And the conclusion was the demand for
Jujitsu was unprecedented.
The world wants to learn Jujitsu.
What didn't exist is structured
distribution mechanisms to get Jujitsu
from our family to the world in
instructure demographic specific ways
that would reach and penetrate all the
necessary audiences so that everyone
could benefit.
Because Teaching Jujitsu to a police
officer who has to go arrest the suspect
nonviolently and keep his gun in his
holster is different than teaching it to
a survivor of sexual assault.
And it's different than teaching it to a
kid who walks to school every day with
his hand sweating because he doesn't
know when that bolt is going to approach
him.
Every one of those needs Jujitsu but how
you communicate it to them is completely
different.
So what we are responsible for is the,
is the specialization of Jujitsu into
demographics,
specific courses,
Gracie,
bulletproof for children,
Gracie survival tactics for law
enforcement,
Gracie combatives for the everyday
civilian who wants to learn self defense
men or women just in the least amount of
time possible.
Women in power to defend against sexual
assault.
All of them are the based on the same
principles,
same concept,
same techniques.
Our family has been perfecting for
almost a hundred years,
but every single one of them is
communicated completely differently to
their audiences.
So that was really our biggest
contribution and then putting that
online so that all of that was
accessible anywhere in the world through
gracie university.com
that's,
that's really cemented our contribution
and now it's just growing and we have
more,
more teaching to do.
But it's all in that thought of,
you know,
making it available for everyone.
Just literally Jujitsu for everyone.
Jujitsu then is a kind of a language,
even from my personal experience of
Jujitsu prior with them.
They're excellent teachers.
I've had back in the UK at Genesis Jam.
I'll give him a little shout out cause I
love him,
Paul and Chris,
like what our thinking is.
Oh Wow.
This thing is like,
it's,
I feel like I'm a little kid saying the
cat is on the mat while they're able to
say,
this feline creature rests now for a
moment on the math,
like watching them move,
watching the patterns,
the lucidness,
the vividness,
the beauty of the language now.
So the inception of a Jujitsu as we
discuss it with respect to your
grandfather was about,
first of all,
this is able to overcome my feelings of
vulnerability and weakness.
Secondly,
this is the most effective form of
combat against even other trained
fighters.
And now what your personal mission has
become as the heads of this part of the
family is the heads of this journey is
you want this language to be understood
by people everywhere.
Yes,
100%
anybody who who you said walks this
planet has insecurities.
All right.
Everybody's worried,
everybody's scared,
everybody's,
you know,
worried about their personal or the
safety of their loved ones.
So there's going to be some time in your
life or something's going to happen when
that day comes.
We talk,
we can provide through digital that they
need to get through that hard time.
But it is literally different languages.
Russell,
for each audience communicating to a
woman if,
if,
if you just speak to a woman who wants
to learn for self defense and to defend
against sexual assault,
Jujitsu in the conventional sense that
night,
the conventional way that 99% of schools
out there,
teachers are too and you were to have
her come in and just try a beginner
class at a school,
she would see no immediate and direct
application between the grappling idea
of two people sweating on each other,
rolling around on the Mat and the
potential for defend against sexual
assault.
She would not see that connect.
Now is there a connection?
Yes,
but she would not see it.
So what we have literally done is
created adapters to make the same
principles communicatable to this
person,
woman,
child,
cop,
anything that makes them say,
oh,
this is not only effective for me.
This was designed exclusively for me and
when you communicated that perfectly to
a fragile,
intimidated,
uncertain beginner students,
you captivate,
then you engage them in the art too.
What would other have not wise happened?
Because you know if you speak to them
with the normal communication language
of Jujitsu and they go,
wow,
this is really kind of actually kind of,
it doesn't seem very fun,
effective.
I don't want to see how I would use this
in real life.
She's going to dismiss Jujitsu after her
first class and I say her,
but I mean,
I even mean men who go to a class and
there are just not tough mma want to.
We've got fighters,
they're just normal civilians and they
come into a class and they go,
wow,
this is freaking nuts.
What they're doing here.
It can be done.
Absolutely quite as all boils down to
how it's communicated.
So the answer is yes,
everyone needs your Jitsu.
Everyone can benefit from Jujitsu,
but if you communicate it wrong,
it's a disaster.
This even even course to course,
like even within the beginner Gracie
combatives course,
you have three new people on their first
day.
Yes.
Even those three have to be communicated
to differently.
That's how special is that 225 pound kid
that just came out of college,
you know,
playing football for three years in
college and now you have somebody who's,
who works at Bank of America down the
street.
Those are two different people in the
same class.
Perhaps energies.
How are you making these individual
evaluations?
What signs are you reading of how a
person needs to be taught and embraced?
What are things that are conveying,
we already know everything we need to
know from the handshake.
The moment just from that we already
know.
We already know that.
We all want to know.
So tell me then from that,
what is from that so tight,
that person to accept.
All right,
I get it.
Listen,
just from that highly energized,
overly eccentric,
potentially an actor and a comedian of
sorts,
and you're coming here,
you're excited to be here,
but you're very nervous.
No,
listen,
I want to have that.
So you're excited to be here.
You've been waiting to learn this stuff
your entire life.
So you're like getting more your
information over.
Let's give it to this guy cause he's
about it right now.
At the same time we can't be too excited
because he's also a very strong,
you can tell from his hands [inaudible]
my hands,
my hands a little sore from that right
now.
So quite tough.
So if we're too excited it might make
him a low too excited.
He won't relax.
Rush to the,
which is what we're experiencing with
you is that no matter how gently we
teach you the moves,
you're over committing to their
execution.
So our talk to you on the Mat as you've
noticed has to have been overly
compensating.
Yeah.
Hey Ross,
look at this and we whispered,
you drink class and you're like,
wow,
why are they still relaxed?
We hope they'll try to bring you down.
We hope that your movements will match
our whisper and then you'll become the
Jujitsu whisper.
When did you learn those things?
Which these are,
these are psychological and amphora per
logical skills.
These are not the,
they obviously clearly intersect with
martial arts.
So when you're little kids with your
father and your uncles,
and we'll have a family members were
significant,
then how are you?
You being taught this stuff at the same
time as you're being taught.
This is how to do a triangle.
Our grandfather always talked about how
whenever he touches someone,
they start getting weak and he has this
energy about him in his aura.
And what he meant was that if I put my
hand on you and my hand is like this,
no matter how tense you are,
it's not going to take too long for you
to also relax versus if I grab you
squeezing,
it's going to make you 10 so when you're
fighting somebody,
it's to our benefit to fight somebody,
but find every moment we can to relax so
that we can bring their energy down.
We can calm them down,
make them feel safe and calm down.
Saint,
just a student like Russell,
you're talking about and we're fighting,
the opponent wants to kill you.
I'm talking about it and how we,
and how we teach him the fight.
You're hypnotized.
The guy.
I'm soft to make him relax,
but where I'm fighting somebody,
I relax to make them go,
ah,
and then block he slices.
But to answer your question,
let's get back on the anthropological
aspect of the connection and the
connection.
Let's talk about this idea of where are
we learn how to teach and connect.
Like let's be clear that the world knows
the Gracie family as a fighting family
for a hundred years is 1920 oh you know,
it's almost a hundred years now.
That's what the world kind of seeds on
the surface.
What we don't feel that way at all.
We feel that we're part of a teaching
family for three generations,
almost a hundred years.
So as much refinement,
dedication,
obsession that has been dedicated to the
process of choking out other human
beings.
That's been a very obsessive process for
the last 100 years.
As much as we've spent on that process
in equal amount of time and energy has
been spent on refining the ability to
transfer our skill set to other people,
is that really true?
100% as much as you're saying,
I'll get right into the crook of the
arm.
It's very important.
You're saying this is the best way to
come in and you're 100% and that's why
we are at the forefront of certifying
other instructors around the world to do
the same things that we're doing and we
have 150 schools today who are all
certified to teach.
These curriculums were telling you about
not just the same techniques but
communicated in the same way and in the
same teaching methodology and that's an
obsession of ours as much as the
fighting itself,
it wouldn't have made sense for my
grandfather,
fathers,
uncles,
cousins to choke everybody out.
All these challenges of other martial
arts and to prove that Jujitsu was the
best and not be ready to receive the
thousands of people that now want to
learn what they just proved to be
effective.
How was it to grow up as young men
transitioning from childhood through
adolescence and puberty with the natural
imperatives to impress your masculinity
and individuality on your family
environment when what goes before you?
Is there sort of a warrior class?
How,
what was it like being teenage boys?
What do you see?
Every day?
I proved my warrior spirit on him.
She,
I'll tell you also,
I prove to my family and everybody,
all my uncles and cousins and my
grandfather,
then I was a warrior by how much I could
beat him up.
So as a young kid,
he did receive a little bit,
I'm sorry,
but that was me trying to prove that I
was warrior and now it was the big thing
because there's a little pressure,
especially at the age of 13,
14 of wanting to be,
you know,
what they were,
which,
which is,
you know,
these,
like you said,
it's warriors.
But,
um,
as you know,
as time passes,
we quickly realized that what they are
is,
it's not just warriors,
they're more than warriors.
They're here to help people in,
to save the world.
So I didn't necessarily see my uncles
and my father as these fighters.
I saw them as men that were making a
difference in changing lives.
Hmm.
So that aspect of it,
the sort of a social and compassionate
aspect was you were aware of that?
Yeah,
quite young.
I think that might've been even a little
stronger,
especially exciting.
Go down the route of fighting
professional,
being an athlete in a fighter.
I went down the route of a teacher,
so maybe I was more influenced by the
teachers that were in the world in my
life.
Hmm.
Although sort of the generation before
you,
there are,
you know,
world renowned fires.
Yes.
Well,
and they were also around teaching,
but they were in a time where nobody
believed that Jujitsu was
best martial art in the world.
When hoists Gracie wins UFC one,
like in the interview straight
afterwards,
what are you gonna do?
He says,
I don't care about the money that they
owe $50,000.
He says,
I watch it every day.
I don't care about the money.
I'm going back to teaching.
That's what you'd like the end of last
week.
That's what he says.
Uh,
so like it's clear that whilst there is
the imperative to prove for presumably
for honor and for mission,
the efficiency of this martial art,
there is a sort of a dedication and a
devotion that's not just about glory,
glamour,
superficial thing.
I mean if you fight,
that's a face you can fight for three
years,
nine years,
12 years,
but you can teach Jujitsu forever and
there's nothing more rewarding than
giving people this,
this magic Jujitsu is magic.
It takes,
took Ellie Gracie from,
you know,
small hundred and you know,
30 pound frail man could,
couldn't do anything to the superhero of
the world.
So this is magic.
We're distributing magic.
Whoever wants it,
we're here to give it.
And there are schools all around the
world doing the same thing.
So doing that,
like there's no problem waking up,
coming to work.
We're not going to work.
We're just going to show up and give
magic.
You see how it is when you walk in here?
I think that part of the reason why this
concept of wow,
you guys are,
there's just such a humility towards
you're here to serve.
You're here to teach this and not to
bask in the glory of winning UFC.
One white voice wasn't very ostentatious
or like you know,
you know too crazy about it.
And I think the reason why it's hard for
the,
the general population to understand
this is because the only other time they
ever see fights or any type of major
competition happen,
it's between two athletes have the same
skillset.
You see a boxer against a boxer to
boxers fight each other with the same
beliefs in boxing.
One guy wins.
So who won that match?
It wasn't a box,
it wasn't boxing that won that match.
It was a boxer,
a person who won the match between two
boxers.
What you have to understand what the
hoist and even our grandfather in the
few challenge matches that we had of
guys who didn't believe in Jujitsu is we
aren't fighting.
Jujitsu is fighting.
Jujitsu won UFC.
One hoists did not.
When UFC one Jujitsu won UFC one and it
beat karate and it beats a vod and it'd
beat boxing and it beat these other
martial arts,
right?
It was more effective than all those
other.
So they get,
that's very important understanding
because you can pull it
and it's also,
it's very significant to keep banging on
about it.
This is significant religious idea.
Most religions are built on the idea
that your individual identity is not as
important as the ideology that is
managing your consciousness.
That if you slide and also surrender the
idea that you surrender,
that you are only a vessel
for our grandfather is the 100% believed
that it wasn't him who won any fights.
It was Jujitsu hoist.
When you see it after UFC one
perpetuates this same conviction that
listen you guys,
I'm,
I'm here,
but Jujitsu is what is special and I
have other brothers who can do just as
well as I can.
I'm not the only one.
I'm just a representative.
Oh.
He very outspoken about the fact that
other brothers could have done what he
did and he was chosen because him and my
dad had a good relationship and hoist
was one of the smaller members of the
family.
So it was actually a more impressive
demonstration of Jujitsu is
effectiveness for someone smaller to be
that vessel.
But absolutely.
Um,
Jujitsu.
Is it religion?
Hmm.
Well,
what that does,
it tells the whole world,
anybody can do it.
Anybody can jump on board and join this
religion of Jujitsu.
Okay.
I'll ask a little more because there's a
very interesting moment in that first
ufc where your father,
I believe,
presents your grandfather with a sort of
a trophy to honor intense.
Your grandfather heard that the energy
is very still intense.
I mean,
even this image of him here that people
watching visually,
we'll see this is something he was
emanate in some thing.
He got a kind of monk energy know,
like what was he like as a human being?
This is like,
he's not,
he's intense.
Right?
You suppose some humility,
I listened to him when he was talking
this humility,
but this is a person that is very,
I know some people that are swamis
priests,
etc.
There's a very sort of a peculiar energy
at the peculiar emanation.
Yes.
He was,
I don't know.
I think present and unfazed.
I think to him,
very few things actually mattered to
him.
Do you know what I'm saying?
So the point is,
ah,
no,
he didn't hear that.
He's right here.
If you're talking to him,
he's talking to you.
If he's teaching you,
you're the world to him.
Oh Wow.
And if you're,
if you do right by him,
he'll do right by you,
the most loyal guy you'll ever meet.
And if not,
he'll just,
you know,
if you guys aren't together,
we're not together.
He's very all or nothing with him.
It was very real with him.
There was never any in between.
And um,
you know,
the absolute and that moment you're
talking about when he received the
award,
he was very,
you know,
whether he was,
it was still in between Hawaii's
fighting.
True.
So he's still in,
he's fighting that night.
That's true.
Jujitsu is fighting his family's fine
Jujitsu twice.
So he's still ain't fight mode.
Right.
Because remember he did this his whole
life.
He says,
bring in so many arenas.
So He's,
he can't quite be smiling yet.
He's still at least there's no
celebration yet.
Yeah.
How come that this award was given in
that context?
You know,
cause this ufc one that's there in lies
the product of when the person who
created the UFC basically can do
whatever you want.
Right?
So this is your father and my father is
giving an award to his soul is a little
bit,
um,
how do you say it?
A little bit.
Um,
you know,
he,
my dad was holding all the cards.
So He created the show and he wanted to
honor someone and he believed that that
is the original ultimate fighter.
And without him there would be no UFC.
So as the creator,
you're allowed to do whatever you want
of the UFC.
You're allowed to do whatever you want.
And to honor the guy who gave birth to
you,
who gave birth to the ability to even
create this type of entity through which
to communicate martial arts,
you can do whatever you want.
He did what made sense.
And it makes only makes perfect sense to
have this guy in the octagon at ufc one
receiving,
especially to everyone who knew that
we're now,
there are some people who booed the
occurrence.
I know because you just want to see more
fight.
You want to see more people wondering
who is this guy?
Why is he getting an award right now?
We don't care.
We want to see more punches and mortar
beer and let's just get crazy right now.
So there was that audience.
But anybody who knew the origin of
Jujitsu,
that UFC gracie family there,
this is absolutely,
if you're enjoying the UFC,
okay,
thank him today.
Even today.
Thank him.
And thank our father hardy on Gracie and
thank every Gracie who's ever fun,
put their neck on the line against other
arts to get it to the point where it can
be this spectacle on television.
Yeah.
How do you feel about how the UFC has
permutate it?
He seems to me like at the FCA is it
become a huge spectacle and a,
it's usually successful and must be
generating a lot of revenue.
But from a person that's doesn't know
very much about it,
it seems that why he's had to do in
order to do that is to let go of many of
their principles of its foundation,
uh,
to align itself as many sports have done
with the principles of consumer
capitalism in order that it can be more
spectacular,
etc.
So how is that?
Well,
everything you just said is what we
feel.
We feel that Jujitsu or the UFC began as
something that was exclusively designed,
make no mistake about it as a vehicle to
demonstrate the effectiveness and
superiority of some arts and the
insufficiencies of up and deficiencies
of other arts.
That's the only reason he was even
conceived.
It was just to show the difference of
different martial arts and it served its
purpose after UFC four,
five,
six,
right in that pocket,
everyone said,
wow,
that little Brazilian guy wrapped up in
the white pajamas,
he's going to win.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that guy in a tie,
you watch,
he's this little skinny guys going.
And once you started becoming where you
knew the outcome before it happened,
Jujitsu had made it to America and to
the world and mission accomplished,
we'll call it from an education
perspective,
and then since then things started
changing on the production side.
They started adding time limits and
rules and weight classes and they
modified the format so much so to make
it more friendly for television and then
eventually thanks to Dana White and the
fertitta brothers,
they made it a sanctioned sport where
people collapse.
It's actually a,
it'd be four.
It was just a fight on TV and then it
became a sanctioned sport,
which even though that was very much
against the origins of what we were
trying to do with the UFC,
and by we,
I mean our father and our ancestors
there,
even though it was against that,
it was absolutely necessary for it to
stick around because it was running into
some political pressure that it was
going to get pretty much terminated
entirely if it didn't make the
adaptations necessary to grow to what it
has today.
And we benefit immensely from its
current popularity today because
Jujitsu's main exposure to the world is
in the,
uh,
through the means of UFC fight where one
guy does a choke hold that you know,
ruined if a chocolate or a triangle
choke,
which is now a household name because of
the UFC.
And because of the,
you know,
millions,
billions of viewers worldwide.
We,
we can say that the UFC today doesn't
allow Jujitsu the way as you gracie
practice use two to be demonstrated.
It's tougher because of the fact that
you have rounds.
He doesn't allow you to let your
opponent exhaust and burn energy while
you're conserving energy forces a little
more of you to push the pace.
So it's not quite the safest Jujitsu,
but yet there are still many amazing
examples of Jujitsu and being done at
principals being performed.
I remember the boxing example how when
two boxers fight,
boxing doesn't win.
A person wins today in the UFC when two
guys fight.
It's not like,
you know,
when we have fighters here who will
represent and fight in the UFC,
who are students of ours,
who we have one is fighting right now in
a few weeks.
Um,
and,
and UFC two 22 and he goes into,
he represents Jujitsu,
he does Jujitsu,
but his opponent is a black belt in
Jujitsu also.
So when he goes in there,
it's not so much Jujitsu one because
they both believe in Jujitsu.
So our students' application of Jujitsu
and his intelligence,
his approach to the fight,
maybe more intelligent and he may
prevail or not.
So it's an individual who's going to
win,
not an art anymore.
And that's what the,
basically what he was talking about is
now you have competitive athletes have
high athleticism and capabilities going
in their testing their individual
attributes more so than the authenticity
or legitimacy of the art they practice.
Cause everyone's packed in the same
stuff.
So,
so that argument has been won this
demonstrating.
So what I telling you,
this is what I know and other aspects of
this conversation I'm interested to
explore is you as men living in the
ordinary world,
what is,
uh,
what's it like for you if you find
yourself in a situation or physical
conflict or if a physical fret,
a emerges,
what is that like and tell us some
stories.
Bad x people love shit like that.
You know,
people say that getting in a fight is
easy and walking away it's difficult,
which I guess I kind of like that.
It's a little,
it was a good little light that line.
But getting in a fight is also easy,
especially if you're scared,
you don't know what to do.
Just go crazy and just attack the person
out of fear.
But for us,
we're like,
I feel like I walk around this world and
I look at 99% of the people in the world
as sheep.
How do,
what do you mean by that?
Like in terms of physical threat,
threat to me,
like they're all sheep.
So if I,
if somebody happens to be cussing at me
in a car honking at me and flipping me
off or in line at a restaurant,
there's this respect done.
I look at that and I say,
man,
there's,
there's zero of that.
I don't need to get my heart doesn't
even race anymore.
What about a Disney world melon example?
I was at Disneyland.
I had a melon in my hand and as I walked
into the hotel,
this man called me.
He said,
look at that guy carrying as melon.
I was with my girlfriend,
my wife now,
and he's,
he said he must be a faggot.
And then I had the melon,
I said,
is he talking to me?
I says,
must be the only guy with a melon.
Everyone's got an unusual,
it's an unusual accessory.
I looked and I thought,
man,
this guy,
why would he say that?
You know?
And I looked at the guy and he has two
kids with him,
a seven and a nine year old.
And I just smiled and I said,
wow,
I have a good day.
And that's it.
But there was no,
I didn't feel like you know what he's
like and I was with my girlfriend.
Especially being with a woman you can
feel like you want to defend your honor
in front of her end up in Charlotte.
Tough you are,
but the fact that he was five,
seven maybe the little easier to walk
away.
Maybe if he was six,
five and really big and a potential
threat.
I might've worn it to prove a little
more but then again I don't even think
so.
I would have still look and said,
sir,
is everything okay just to be clear.
I want to,
if he wants,
if he really to fight,
we kind of have to give them the option
for you,
your confidence in this martial art as
moved you to a place where the
circumference of fear in much fervor,
way it would for you violence or
confrontation or combat is something
that would only occur when absolutely
necessary.
Probably much more likely to happen to
me because I was like like in the vote,
like if something like that happens for
me,
panic,
fear,
chaos,
demonstration.
People don't realize how they,
how much they contribute to making a
street fight happen.
That's interesting.
Right when you,
it was an argument between two people at
the top.
If we know what we're yelling,
then there's pushing other punching in
their Friday.
So we have,
so we're contributing.
We can either make it a fight or we can
make it a conversation that ends right
there.
So knowing how to respond to somebody
that's pissed off,
he took their parking spot or who's who
you ask them to look at their girlfriend
in an inappropriate way,
knowing how to speak to that person.
It means everything and how you speak to
them stems from how you feel and if you
feel like everything's okay and that
you're not going to be hurt and that if
you do get in a fight,
it will all be fine.
Then you're going to speak to a much
more code.
If you don't feel safe.
If you don't feel prepared to handle the
physical altercation that might happen.
You're going to respond in fear and that
fear is going to escalate.
The combative energy between us,
the way you have to look at it is you
have to imagine that between,
and you don't deny there is a meter and
everything he says either increases the
combative energy or decreases it.
Everything.
There is no neutral increased or
decreased and everything I say is going
to increase or decrease.
But here's what's interesting is that I
can only reach the threshold that it
needs to reach for the fight to actually
happen.
You have to reach a certain threshold,
right?
It's not going to happen from a calm
composed civil conversation unless
someone's out to assault you and rob you
with their own intention.
But in terms of the street fights that
we typically think of,
which is someone looks at,
someone goes like that and now I'll
fight is on like that situation to
happen.
It has to reach a certain energy and
when he don't says when I come up and I
bumped in or I say,
why did you do this?
Or why'd you look at her?
What the elder and I get excited and he
responds with equal excitement and fear
and any energy that creates that
escalation.
And then once it hits the threshold,
someone's going to push someone and then
someone's going to swing in.
The fight is on,
you know what we're saying is,
but knowing how to fight makes it to
where you can respond to that initial
stimulus so calmly that they go,
man,
what's this guy guys?
These guys freaking guy partially
believe something.
I kind of believe there's,
there's nothing someone can do to make
me fight them other than attack me right
now.
Even if they had their hand on my
shoulder,
like,
yeah,
you don't know man.
Even then they're not attacking you.
They're still talking to me.
I don't take that as an attack or as
most people,
he put his hand on me.
But when it becomes a fight,
so there's,
there's very few things you can do to
make it a fight.
And what is one throat punch?
It's it to go over a headlock.
That's it.
Anything other than punching me or
trying to grab my whole body,
there's no fight going down.
It makes me realize that in my own life,
not even outside of the idea of physical
combat,
in the idea of just emotional,
where there will be no physical
conflict,
romantic relationships even or the
equivalent of putting the hand on my
shoulder.
I'm too easily triggered as a person.
I'm too busy looking for problem,
problem,
fear,
fear like it's too much in my makeup,
you know,
like it's too much in my makeup.
Um,
but uh,
more,
uh,
local example before we drop deeper
again,
uh,
what about what you told me the house of
Blues Story.
So little stories.
My now wife then girlfriend were at the
house of Blues over there in Anaheim.
We were watching our friends also might
be amazing.
Uh,
Latin dog crew and they're doing their
music thing and I'm in there and it's
great music and uh,
I'm standing with even,
it's a semi crowded situation and
there's a guy to my immediate right here
who basically created his own marsh pit
by himself,
by himself.
He's mushing alone cause just poor and
poor going gold.
And then bought me once and I'm like,
all right,
I'm a passive patient,
gentle guy.
And he bumps me again and I'm like,
he's having a good time.
But it got to the point where you know
you wanted to match with him,
you want a match.
We got to the point where he was making
it unpleasant because I was not able to
focus on the,
the,
the party.
And then I thought,
well we could just move.
But then the problem is I would permit
him to continue his behavior,
which would make it unpleasant for other
people around round him.
So the conclusion was made that he had
to be dealt with.
And I thought,
okay,
you know how to,
it's very noisy and I couldn't just say,
excuse me sir.
Excuse me.
It would be two out of the Er.
I had to get his attention.
So this might be the first time there's
a necessary physical demonstration.
Is it,
is it possible?
Can you cover this?
Cause you,
I can say it right here.
It's pretty fascinating.
Yeah,
I'll do it.
To Russell the,
yeah,
so he's here,
my machine.
I said,
hey man can tell you having a very good
time,
but I'm not right here with you bumping
into me every second.
So why don't we call him down and let's
continue to watch the music said.
What are the significant aspects of
that?
Well,
first of all,
I just had to,
and I didn't yell at him.
I whispered to him like it was like
that.
Even though it was noisy,
like I was so close that I didn't have
to go.
So as you can see what I entered right
here,
it's one hand on the neck.
I don't like that feel.
I'm the head of the tricep right here.
One hand the triceps.
So right now I'll put me in the face
right here.
Can't I'm too close.
Turn in country.
The other hand,
I've got you right here.
We're in the clean shot.
Ready?
We got them.
Okay,
so we're already a have a tactical
position right here.
I've safety.
But this right here sends a message.
What does it says?
Control.
It's like,
I think we've animals.
Like when you put a puppy in your mouth.
I know I don't put puppies in my mouth.
When your mum was a puppy in its mouth,
I think that sending a very old message
deep into the biology,
this brought him back to when he was
like for his dad would grab him.
I'm like,
don't call on the wall [inaudible] know
about your past,
but all we know is this.
Listen the guy absolutely still,
and he didn't even look at me.
That's what's crazy is that he wasn't
even in a position to look at me like
my,
this thumb right here has a little bit
of a pressure point of pass a field
that,
and I just whispered this right here and
he knew what he was doing cause he knew
he bumped into me already.
So after I let go,
I said,
are we cool?
Yeah.
Sounded like that was it.
And I didn't move and he didn't match
anymore.
The the,
the mosh pit was done and here's the
deal.
He didn't know who I was.
He didn't know what I could have fought
me.
I mean,
I did assert myself a little bit there,
but that was a situation where calm,
assertive,
calm,
accomplish many things because when you
can remain calm and put your hands on
somebody,
if you have two,
or even in communication,
let's say it was a totally not noisy
situation,
and I said,
listen man,
you're a behavior is getting a little
out of control.
I don't appreciate it and I'm going to
have to have you calm down a little bit
and I can talk to him like that and I
can be calm and composed and direct with
someone.
People appreciate that and they go,
man,
either he has a gun or he used the black
vote at something or he knows something
and that you know that the ability to
compose yourself that way comes from
Jujitsu cause,
sorry,
the terror
trey off putting your hand on someone's
neck and doing that.
I think that's already Jujitsu master
territory.
I think for me,
I think if I would be,
if I was going to confront someone in
that kind of way,
I think that would be a little too,
I think that'd be a little too
aggressive to do that.
So like you know,
like because it's,
for me,
I think I wouldn't be feeling very calm.
Basically.
It's good to know that the things that
you did was,
you spoke quietly,
you did something that was controlling.
I think for most people that are
novices,
the kind of situation is going to happen
is when someone direct
c'mon front,
she would just have an attitude with
you.
Yeah,
and you know what we say is this,
you know,
Egos and alcohol,
99.9%
of fights,
altercations that happened today would
be completely nonexistent if you remove
the egos and the alcohol from the
equation.
Right?
Oh,
I've taken the alcohol out,
but in the ego's bad,
I know you said that on the front door,
the door mat here,
he says,
leave your ego here.
Why do you think that?
What do you mean by that?
You're,
you're,
you're the funeral.
They had to prove to everybody that
you're the best.
Everybody.
Isn't this the proving ground in many
ways they want to,
everybody wants to be the best on the
mat.
So don't worry about being the best you
can.
Try to execute proper technique and
defeat each other.
But this idea of,
you know,
you're greater than everybody else.
You know what's funny about that,
Matt though,
is that it says,
leave your ego at the door as if you
have a choice.
You know,
it's crazy as shit.
It should say,
pick your ego up right here when you
leave.
That's what it should say.
Huh?
Because it's just not coming in with you
because whoever comes in with the ego,
guess what happens?
It gets taken out.
And when it gets taken out of you,
if you can let your ego,
well,
yeah,
I mean,
my point is even when you come in for
your first class,
we said,
Hey Russell,
how would you escape this position?
And you go,
ah,
I can't,
and then we say,
well,
try this and you go about it as much
better.
So you had to let go of the fact that
you had the answer.
In order to learn the new answer,
you have to empty the cup to fill it
back up again.
So when someone comes in,
if they get into the class and they
don't want to accept the fact that they
don't have the answer for a particular
threat scenario,
they can't learn the new answer and they
typically will leave before they ever
do.
So the students who stick around,
all of them have to detach themselves to
some degree from there.
A preexisting egos otherwise won't even
make it in the building.
And one small thing and speaking night,
egos and alcohol.
This idea when somebody confronts you in
the street,
right?
Just very natural nail and the words are
exchange and looks when you know,
if you want to avoid a fight in a heated
moment like that where there's words
being exchange,
think about what you have to do in that
moment.
And it's your ego.
You have to be okay saying to whoever it
is that you're arguing with.
I apologize.
I crossed the line.
I made a mistake.
I see.
Why you're angry at somebody.
I shouldn't have done that.
It's not,
I don't know what I was thinking.
How can you want to fight me when I say,
hey,
you're right.
I don't know where I was thinking,
I crossed the line.
I'm going to move back.
I'm not going to do that again.
Start Defense.
If we instead feel like it may be I was
right,
I can say no,
you shouldn't have said that and I was
here first.
That kind of attitude.
There's no,
there's no point.
It's going to lead to a fight.
We're willing to do whatever it takes
not to fight and there's good reasons
why you guys listen via avoidance of the
fight is the most,
especially for our viewers and
listeners,
the avoidance of a street fight,
even one that might seem absolutely
eminent,
it's unavoidable is the most important
selfdefence tip you'll ever learn in
your life.
I've never been in a street fight.
I was wondering when I was in seventh
grade and that was the last one.
I was 1213 years old.
That's the last fight I've ever been in
my size.
A little bit of a diffusing situations.
But the point is this,
the street fight,
even the street fight that you win,
you often lose.
Because think about this,
you get into a fight,
you fall down,
you know you take someone down,
your elbow hits the ground,
you get stitches,
you gotta go to the hospital after you
get an infection,
staph infection and you won the fight.
Let's you say you won.
Or let's say for our friends who don't
know Jujitsu,
you get into a street fight,
someone pops up,
you puff up,
they puff up your profile,
you swing and you crack them and you
chipped her tooth.
And now you have a $20,000
dental bill on your hands.
Because we live in a litigious society.
So self defense doesn't just mean how to
avoid getting knocked out.
Defense means self preservation,
preservation of your finances so you
don't get sued.
Preservation of your body.
If you get in this fight and you get
beneath someone and you're in the bottom
of the guard and let's say they have a
bloody nose cause you hit him on the way
in and now they're bleeding on you.
There is,
you know there is blood borne diseases
are transferred sexually transmitted
diseases and the blood born illnesses
that can be transferred.
So you don't want someone bleeding on
you in a fight.
You want to avoid anything that has to
do with the fight.
So this idea of don't fight because it's
the right thing you did know.
Don't fight because it's a stupid thing
to fight if you can avoid it.
Any costs you want to avoid a fight.
And I feel like too many people thinking
about self defense,
that's just the ability to win the
fight,
not the ability to avoid it altogether.
Very difficult to overcome that because
we live in quite a Marshall Society.
We live in a city.
Like if you take the example of what's
happening in UFC,
something that started as a
demonstration of the efficacy of a
particular Marsha are in universal or
open conditions became controlled.
And regulated for the purposes of
commercial purposes,
it seems to me it as well.
Another thing that I'm learning for us
from my early experiences of Brazilian
Jujitsu,
it's about very much awareness.
It's
about having an awareness of your life
as a whole.
Like,
you know,
I don't want to get into confrontations
and an awareness of the prison.
While I'm listening to the two of you
talk,
I'm continually thinking these are
universal principles.
These are applicable outside of the art
of Jujitsu,
an outside of combat that when I'm
approaching my work,
when I'm approaching my relationships,
stay in the moment,
think I'm with this woman for the rest
of my life.
So why do I want to have a big argument
where I say something damaging or with
my child,
I have a relationship with last river
through.
It's not in a sense,
it's like the combat and conflict
because it is so vivid.
It's more of the,
it makes certain principals more
obvious,
also applicable in all communication.
Because I suppose as we've said earlier,
this is a language.
This is a,
uh,
a,
a form of communication.
And one of the things I've noticed with
both of you and even that demonstration
is that's a communications expert.
That's someone who knows how to
communicate in a very,
very expert way.
And possibly the reason you've not had
any street fights is because for the
last 20 years you've been neck cramping
people.
Well,
every time I leave my house,
I only did that one time.
But I will say this,
we go to the principal's,
you're referencing a,
it's beautiful because you know we talk
about self defense and fight and not
fight and egos and alcohol.
But what's crazy is that for every one
time that I've ever had the touch
someone,
there's that blue's house of blues and
there was the one in seventh grade.
I have applied shit,
absolute core Jujitsu principles on the
business front,
on the personal front a thousand times
to one.
What's an example of the welcome to the
party,
Bro?
Let's talk.
How many do we have time for?
So this is what's so beautiful and
here's what's crazy Russell,
is that we,
this is true for our lives.
100% Jujitsu is life.
Life is your Jitsu because these
principles are universal that we're
going to demonstrate or combat
principles.
There are 17 noncombat principles that
apply to,
uh,
to everyday life into business and
relationships and we'll talk about a few
whatever we have time for it.
But here's what's crazy is that our
students who train with us start for
self defense,
but they stick for the life application
of everything.
We're learning here that once you've
trained for six months,
including you,
five,
six,
seven months of good Jujitsu,
you'll never need to train again for
self defense reasons,
you'll be okay.
You'll know how to manage distance.
You know how to avoid getting knocked
out.
You at least won't go to the hospital
and you're good to go.
That's all you need for a fight.
Just don't get beat up.
You'll have that ability in a few months
with Jujitsu,
but then why keep training for 16 years?
Because every single day you come to
class,
you're reinforcing principles that we're
going to demonstrate right now.
All right,
we got on the floor and now we're here.
Come on.
Just going to be safe.
I'll call commentary because our friends
at home who are listening to this,
we're going to do the best we can,
but let's just demonstrate one here
called position before submission.
Critical principle,
the right move at the wrong time is the
wrong move.
He don't as right now mounted on me.
It's called the mountains you do to both
knees over my body.
And what amazing submission from right
here is he pins the arm down.
He locks his elbow and he goes under my
arm,
grabs my own risks.
And this is called the Americana arm
lock.
All yes.
Did you right now and slide my hand down
and my shoulder will dislocate right
here and I'll be in excruciating pain
and I'll either tap or scream fights
over.
He wins.
Americana arm lock,
great technique.
And what was that principle and notch
position before?
So he's mounted on me.
Go on my guard.
He don't?
No,
he don't get to go inside my guard.
It's called the guard.
Inside my laser.
Very common position in MMA.
He's going to do the exact same
technique,
but watch her dive on it.
He don't drive on it.
Watch what happens
and now it's like,
so why the exact same technique was
completely useless and not only useless
but actually dangerous for him using the
technique from a different position.
So as he dives across and go American
arm lock,
right,
it looks correct,
hand grabs his other,
I'm going to go under.
The problem is this,
when you do the Americana from within
someone's legs,
lock it up,
they can create an angle on you shoot
this leg through and they can get up on
your back.
Because my legs are around,
heat owns body,
I have control of the position even
though he's applying the right
submission.
So the question then becomes,
well what are the implications for this?
You can join us down here,
have a seat there.
And so the question becomes what is this
actual show boomers down here?
The question becomes what is the
implication of this in a,
in an off the mat sense position before
submission,
the right move from within the wrong
position is the wrong move.
So let's just say that you have a
product or you have a service or a plan
of action or something.
And you're offering your product to the
marketplace and is not doing well.
Let's say something you're really
passionate about though,
you're extremely believing in this
product.
This is your American arm lock and it's
not doing well in the marketplace where
you have to reflect on and say,
wait a minute.
If the Americana is something that I
know I'm supposed to be doing and I'm
supposed to be selling,
why isn't it succeeding?
And the question is,
are you in the right position?
Are you selling it for the right price?
Are you doing it to,
are you offering it to the right market
demographic?
Are you,
are you highlighting the correct and
most beneficial,
uh,
benefits or properties of the product or
service?
And to make sure it has the most
effective penetration in the market
place and how he did it for the right
reasons,
for the principle of service.
Are you doing this to create common
zone?
Is your position correct on what you're
offering or servicing?
So this is the first one,
transposition position before
submission.
So you can have the best American if you
do it from the guard,
you're dead.
If you do it from the mount,
you win the fight.
Same Americana,
different application position and it's
completely different effectiveness.
The question is what's your Americana in
your life and are you operating from the
right principal and the right position?
Failing forward.
You don't get me in the guard.
You going to do an arm lock right there.
Check this out you guys.
So
the question is in the garden,
beautiful technique for he don't and we
talked about how before you,
I should not go for the Americana cause
he can take my back,
but flip the script.
Now what can he do from the guard that
is so amazing if I'm strangling him or
choking him,
he creates an angle.
His legs fly up and he breaks my elbow
right here.
He's holding my wrist,
he's hyper extending my elbow with his
hips and I either tap or snap right
here.
It's a done deal.
They're beautiful technique.
Let's do it again.
And this principles called failing
forward so you don't do it.
Go for it,
spinned for it,
catch it.
Look what happens every my arm out and
then from here liquidy does.
Then the fights over.
So what happened right there?
I ripped my arm out of the arm bar.
So in a more,
at first glance,
you look at that and say,
wow,
the opportunity was stripped away from
them and 99% of the world would see that
as a lost opportunity.
He sees it as a perfect triangle set up.
So don't you notice how in society,
and you'll show it one more time.
Then we'll talk about the actual
application here.
He makes an angle and breaks the arm
right here.
When he's going for the arm lock,
he wants my,
I'm to stay here,
but if I rip this arm out,
he can't do that move anymore because
this is the wrong arm.
Watch,
try this.
He can't break this arm because my arm
bends this way.
It's normal.
It's this arm that he would have liked
to had broken.
Great.
So from here,
when that fails and that's no longer
available,
this leg just comes around my neck and
crosses around my neck and now put it in
the hip turn and I'm completely
chalkable.
Not just chalkable,
but specifically because I ripped this
arm out.
I'm 100% exposing myself to a better
technique and the aftermath.
So before we ever apply this as an
fiddler philosophy,
just as a combat position,
fasc incredible because you're on the
line he had on his,
on the floor,
on your back.
But from care,
the armbar being available is amazing
because this is a technique that I've
learned in the last few days were very
beautiful technique.
And then even if that arm is removed,
if you're conscious enough,
if you're awake enough,
there is the opportunity to move the leg
to the other side of their head.
And then you're just saying if you don't
wake it,
the opportunity's there and you're
prepared to seize it because think about
this,
no matter who you are,
what your profession is,
what's your passion is,
what's your pursuit is you're going to
have setbacks,
there's going to be personal setbacks,
individual,
your life circumstance,
something happens,
throws you off your rail.
There's going to be industry setbacks.
Let's say like the comedy industry takes
a hit and no loans going to shows
anymore.
Who knows?
Jujitsu just takes a spike and then may
have whatever there's gonna be an
industry set back and then there's going
to be potentially a,
a society setback where there's an
economic downfall.
Everyone's on a crash and things are
tough.
But don't you notice how sometimes in
the setbacks people losing suffer,
but there's always some superstars who
come out and they capitalize and they
win when everyone else is losing.
Don't you wonder what operating system
are they on that allows them to
capitalize and grow to the extent that
they are when everyone else seems to be
failing in the same environment?
Right?
And the answer is this.
When you are going for the arm bar and
an arm rips out and you're mourning the
loss of the arm bar,
there is no ability to see the new
opportunity that's there.
So the key of this principle called
failing forward is
allow unfortunate circumstances to
happen,
observed them,
but immediately once they happen,
know that they no longer exist.
It,
that they're there and they move on.
And now what you observe of the present
situation and what the opportunities are
and there's,
I've never caught a triangle that I
didn't believe was there or would be
there.
So when someone rips in our mouth,
I'm not mourning the loss.
I'm actually expecting the triangle
that's going to come next.
So when opportunity meets preparation,
amazing things will happen.
The challenge for most people is they're
not putting in the preparation time when
everything is going well so that when
things go bad they can capitalize when
everyone else is suffering from the loss
and one so you'll mentality in life or
on the mat is that when something could
appear to be a crisis that this is going
to be an opportunity for you.
Now this is something,
again,
I have to place this in a framework
where I understand it and I said to hit
on you have a day like in a standup
comedy situation.
If I'm in a good frame of mind,
if someone shouts something from the
audience,
this is brilliant.
This is an opportunity for me.
I'm going to be funny with that person.
I'm going to talk to that person.
But if I'm feeling nervous that night,
I just think,
no,
that's messing with my deal.
This is not how I wanted it to go.
So again,
this is a spiritual principle of non
attachment.
This is the principle of allowing the
world to be how it is and responding to
it rather than thinking your personal
will is what's important now then you
see though,
uh,
her know that there is a continual hat.
Like if I may,
it seems like there is a tension between
any principal of individual mastery and
uh,
the principal of sort of of surrender.
How do you get into this position of
expertise as martial artists and keep
yourself kind of grounded?
How do you do that?
How do you not become yourself over
incensed by ego too.
I want this to be the most successful
university.
I don't need this to happen,
you know,
like how do you do that?
Because there is so much,
you know,
Latin for me,
I have to watch myself from.
I do.
If I have a lot of things go right for
me.
Like,
oh my God,
look how amazing I was in that show.
I have to work quite hard to go.
You're very lucky you didn't make that
happen.
You're lucky you've got born with
certain abilities at a time where people
value that,
that you had this luck when you were
that age.
When that thing happened to you.
I have to re tell myself a story because
my natural propensity will be to claim
it back for the ego to pick the ego
backup on the doormat on the way out,
you know?
So how do you,
so how are you applying continually
these spiritual principles to maintain
your own egos in check with the
successes that you have experienced as,
as Jujitsu wise and as meant?
It's a good question.
I think what comes to mind for me as
cautious optimism.
I'm very optimistic,
very hopeful.
I hope for the best,
prepare for the worst mindset,
you know,
so,
um,
be grateful for what we have.
And I think in Jujitsu,
Jujitsu itself is such a humbling
practice.
The very nature of what we're doing is
so humbling to come to the mat,
train with these guys.
And other,
you know,
talented training partners and realize
what,
you know,
what you don't know and continuously
sharpening that sword that you never get
too high.
But the confidence that drew to gives
you also prevents you from ever getting
too low.
So you stay in this very healthy place
that even when things are going
exceptionally well,
you know that hey,
I've got to prepare for the worst.
Now he's got to be thinking about what's
in the accident.
Growing and planting and Jujitsu is
three four moves ahead.
So that game planning for Jujitsu in a
real fight can be applied to,
you know,
to business and to entrepreneurial-ism
100% and I think that believing that you
know,
things are good,
but things were,
any of that that's high is going to be
low.
Anything that's low is going to be high.
So if you right in the middle and always
planning for the next step,
you're going to have your best chance to
see.
Here's the thing that I've experienced
is that I think is perhaps different.
I'm a 12 step person because of the
alcohol and the drugs and I think 12
steps is about dealing with crisis.
This is for people that have been broken
in life and sounded like,
cause I think that I have in a 12 steps
a philosophy that is very applicable.
You admit something is a problem,
you believe it could improve,
you accept help from people or entities
if you believe in that kind of thing but
more experienced and more powerful than
you.
Then there were some administrative
steps and some other principals as well,
but I think that from what I've
experienced that this is something that
becomes relevant when you have become
broken,
when you have become destroyed,
which does sound comparable to what your
grandfather experienced.
It sounds like a man.
They experience that kind of humiliation
of some kind and it's a experience of
humiliation.
So you're saying that when you're,
like earlier in the conversation we
talked about how Brazilian Jujitsu,
we will be applicable to a wide
demographics to children that are afraid
to,
people that are worried about sexual
assault to law enforces so,
but it seems to me as well that these,
you know,
the reason I'm interested in this,
of course I'm excited by a martial art
where people see more brilliant and
glamorous.
I love that who doesn't?
But what was more important to me is
that it seemed philosophically flexible
and applicable beyond even the,
you know,
as we've just discussed beyond the realm
of the martial art,
I feel like,
I feel like a Jujitsu practice is like,
you know,
a week out in everyday life.
Like thinking about the things that go
down in one practice,
especially when you're fighting against
each other,
you're experiencing so many hardships.
You're failing,
right?
You're being outsmarted,
you're being manipulated.
These things are happening to you while
you're grappling were being tricked and
you know,
we were being threatened.
You feel like you're under pressure.
You're,
there's the risk of injury.
There's all these things happening.
Especially right now amongst us to as
black belts finding each other.
Yeah.
How is that?
When there is,
it's,
it's like a war.
So when these things go down and we'd
learned to deal with things,
these things on the spot,
on the spot,
I experience immense threat.
Yeah.
I mean I have to fall back and use what
I've learned my whole life with that
threat.
So I just practiced it like you talked
about earlier in our 10 minute session,
we did a fight.
So three days later when I feel threat,
I'm,
I'm at home.
I feel threat every day.
He said it,
you know,
everything you experienced in a,
in a,
you know,
five or 10 minute Jujitsu training
session that that presents all the
emotions and highs and lows of a month
or six months of the average person
experiencing it out in life or business
or personal relationships.
So we're basically creating these,
this petri dish of experimentation and
have constant,
a refinement of our ability to handle
those outside stimuli,
uh,
in a,
in a fighting stance.
And let's be honest.
When you can be comfortable applying
your living principles in a fight
against another human being,
then there's nothing that you're going
to be uncomfortable dealing with.
I think in my own personal psychology as
a mountain,
and that's the only gender I'm qualified
to speak for the age informs a lot of my
behavior way beyond actual conflict.
I think the imagined threat of conflict
really informs me psychologically.
I've,
you know,
and fear as a phenomenon and what I
sense is,
is that if I personally spent time
around this kind of energy,
it gives me a different sense of
groundedness.
He opened out my spirituality into
another area.
It seems like,
uh,
it seems like something I've neglected a
lot in life and something that it feels
like it's a good puzzle piece.
It connects me in a way that's very,
it's fascinating to me.
It really means when I look at people,
I want to look at every single person on
this planet and look at them and feel
good.
I don't want to look at someone and feel
like,
ah,
you know,
what?
An anger or fear or anything negative.
I only want to feel good and no matter
how negative they are.
So I just think about myself as a,
you know,
a spiritual and a balanced person.
You know,
Jujitsu allows me to be the best person
I can be.
The nicest,
most peaceful person of all.
Everybody says the very common quote is,
I'm a lover,
not a fighter.
That's why I do Jujitsu cause I'm a
lover,
not a fighter.
There's no question about it.
If you've been in those sessions,
a lot of it did seem more like fighting
and loving.
You were fighting,
he was loving.
But think about how if you don't want to
do the martial large because you're a
lover,
what that means is when you're
threatened,
how are you going to defend yourself by
hurting the person because you don't
know how to do it any other way.
You can only hurt the person to defend
yourself.
Me and the other hand,
I practice fighting all day.
So when you attack me,
I can love you back.
I think it would be remiss to her to
wrap up this interview without me being
involved in some demonstration of a move
because I've realized I've really,
really loved this conversation.
I've loved hanging out at the Gracie
University Gracie Academy for this week.
It's been brilliant.
I can't endorse it hardly enough but
like a,
I think it like the punch block series
and the guards and we showed them the
one that we had worked on in stages one
through four.
Have you seen you guys reviewed some of
that?
We did it.
Let's do it.
So let's talk about,
and this is comfort and worst case
scenarios.
This is come from worst case scenarios,
the next peaceable and beautifully you
want to go out.
So we're going to do it.
Yeah,
you wanna get his guard going to do it.
I'll talk to the principal here and
Russell we'll be doing here with here in
the bottom of the guard right here off
my Westham soc.
So that would be something of that
football club.
So yeah,
you guys want to slide down south a
little bit.
Come down a little bit.
So in the guard,
wrap him up in Stage one russell,
you have head control arm control here
real quick.
Wrap me up in stage.
He lands down here.
It has no plan.
Worst case scenario,
so imagine it Russell.
Imagine being here with zero gt to
knowledge.
What would someone do in your position
who knew nothing right now?
The panic,
panic protect their face and he would
just drop bombs through the cage,
around the corner in the body.
You're going to eventually get opened up
and getting knocked down from you.
This they're actually for most people
watching.
This is actually worst case scenario.
But when you understand Jujitsu and you
understand a little bit of distance
management concept,
which Russell has learned from us,
we can demonstrate it now.
It's a series of stages to mitigate this
threat and be able to stay safe and calm
as a result of that.
So stage one is when Russell had him
wrapped up,
get inside and hug his head.
Rustled the head and arm control that we
talked about yet.
Wrap that arm and you're here.
This is called stage one.
And then if,
let's say we're here and he don't start
trying to pull body punches,
bring your knee and side Russell and
that stage to other knee.
So now he's blocking punches at the
second stage of protection.
If he don't sits up,
he's on his chest,
rust it,
look at that.
He's blocking now at stage three now he
don't,
can't reach punches from there cause
it's too far.
And if he stands up stage,
you don't on the hips,
this is called stage four.
So with all these stages you noticed
that how he was never at the range to
knock you out.
And then from there punch punch,
let him back in,
rust,
wrap his head up and he's back to stage
one.
So it's a cycle and you can go from
stage one to stage three,
stayed up to three right there and he's
on his chest book or for Direct Punch
Punch.
Let him back in.
Boom,
boom.
And he pulls him back down.
So to be able to meet and what happens
throughout all these exchanges,
he's burning energy trying to hit you
and you're just managing the distance.
So we can't knock you out.
So he's exhausting while you're
preserving,
having a lovely cuddle,
if you relax,
if you relax like we talked about,
and don't tense up to me,
why are you doing it?
Why south tense?
It's me.
And then you control from here.
And then we have your triangle.
Why don't you do to try and bring your
own inside of the here?
Bring your knee inside.
So that's where you push his arm away.
Bring your knee inside his arm slowly.
Yeah,
she didn't comes in.
Now slide two is risk to your boss and
I'll pull your leg up and around his
neck.
Beautiful.
Cross that leg.
Get the arm across.
Shoves his arm over and I'll grab his
head.
He'd lock your legs up nice and tight
there.
Squeeze your thighs together,
grab your Shin tight thighs.
Everything's squeezed down and pull your
head down,
puts his head down.
Squeeze your driver's head,
grab his head.
You Think,
oh,
he's said s six seconds.
And that principle right there is called
the wind wind principle.
You do the move you,
he taps out and you let go.
Everybody wins.
If you could think about this,
you didn't hurt me,
hurt my ego.
He neutralized,
probably went for a triangle and I feel
a little pressure on my neck and then I
tap or I cough a little bit and then you
release.
You didn't,
he didn't punch my face and break my
nose and have to let go of me and say,
Hey,
is everything cool here?
And I kind of like,
you know,
half fell asleep but say I pass out a
little bit and now we can stand up and
have a cup of tea.
There doesn't have to be this.
No alcohol.
That was cause I'm English,
right.
No,
no alcohol.
That's lovely to be able to neutralize
the threat for the,
to be able to put out the fire without
adding more fire to it.
Yes.
She able to stop violence without
violence.
Do you see how this is so applicable to
bulletproof and into a child who's
getting bullied?
Because if you have a child,
what you do,
congratulations.
And they're growing up three,
four,
five,
six years old and someone's picking on
them and you didn't have Jujitsu to
teach them,
you would say,
hey child,
go over there and punch him in the nose
because you don't have another resource
to help them stand up for themselves.
And then you basically turn your child
into the bully to fight the bully.
But Jujitsu is,
it's such a gentle approach to the same
threats that it neutralizes it.
And they could literally be friends
after the altercation is complete.
My children,
they will not even call Jujitsu fighting
if the time comes where they're getting
bullied and they're at seven years old
and nine years old and they start doing
Jujitsu,
they didn't fight the kid at school.
They just controlled the situation.
If we think of it as fighting,
then we're gonna turn our kids do this.
No,
change your idea of what it means for
your kids to stand up for themselves and
fight back.
When you use Fujitsu,
you're not fighting back.
That's an [inaudible].
I've already fought that mark.
I want to teach my doula mabel that like
that.
You know when she says I am angry to say
no,
you're not angry.
Just in this moment you are experiencing
anger.
The anger will pass,
but you are saying that you could
reframe the whole way they see the
world,
but even a situation which a lot of
people live with fear of physical
violence,
you could see it as just as,
oh this is that thing happening where I
do the gentle cuddling of Jujitsu.
We'd be doing this on your do a on the
at home with them just on the carpet.
You just played Jujitsu so they won't
hesitate to tackle the kid that's been
bugging them for the last year.
They don't see that as a fight.
They see that as a,
as a physical resolution to a threat
scenario,
but not as a violent proposition.
Therefore,
there should be no barrier to prevent
them from doing what they need to do
because the biggest problem,
and we did a video of this recently with
our friend Vince Vaughn,
who's also a student,
and we talked about this concept of the
biggest kind of threatened concern you
have for kids in schools is not even the
bully.
It's the policies that are implemented
to try to prevent bullying,
the called zero tolerance kind of
bullying policies,
which means if someone's teasing you,
that's wrong,
but if you stand up for yourself,
you're also wrong.
So you're going to both get in trouble.
And that's a problem because then a
child is paralyzed by a policy and will
not defend themselves because they're
not allowed to fight at school.
Anybody who is involved in a fight is
wrong.
Both kids get suspended.
So you have a policy that's meant to
help the victims of bullying,
but it actually enables the bullies
because if I tease you and poke you,
I know you can't stand up for yourself
because you'll get in trouble if you do.
So the good kids are handcuffed.
The bad kids take advantage of the fact
that no one else can stand up to them
and they can get away with all the
bullying they want.
So it's a parent's job to say,
Hey,
son or daughter,
whatever the school policy is,
don't worry.
You can always do your self defense.
You can always neutralize any threat
against you in a nonviolent way and
you're never going to be wrong with me.
And if it's wrong with the school,
all deal with the school myself.
But if a child needs to hear that from
their parents and otherwise they remain
handcuffs serious.
And back to what you said when you're in
the principal's office.
Yes.
You know you're in trouble for fighting.
I wasn't fighting principal.
I wasn't fighting.
I was just neutral.
You would be the person talking to them
with a whole,
I didn't fight.
I didn't punch him.
I want to make them.
I just held him down until the teacher
came fighting his punches and kicks.
What world are you from?
This is very beautiful.
I think that you have reframing a lot of
things.
You're reframing fear,
you're reframing conflict and come back.
You're helping me to address things I
think like the psychological issues that
probably laying about in the landscape
of my mind and addressed for a very long
time.
Very,
very grateful to both of you.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] gracie on,
or if you come visit us,
man,
come anytime and hopefully you can make
it down to California more often.
We can roll more.
We can talk more.
I'm going to be doing a lot of pushups
between now and when I next see you.
I think you're going to be impressed
with the results.
Thank you so much.
Thanks,
John.
Thank you for your Nice,
wow.